We're back in the 90s for the first awesome
Captain Marvel trailer and boy does it look
fantastic!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm breaking down the trailer
for loads of marvellous easter eggs and crucial
details you might have missed.
And to celebrate the Captain Marvel trailer,
I'm kicking off a new superhero giveaway,
so make sure you're subscribed to my channel
and leave me comment below on the trailer
for a chance to win!
The first detail you might have missed comes
in this brief shot in a lab deep inside a
SHIELD building.
If you zoom in really close, you'll see Nick
Fury with a gun presumably ready in case the
Skrull on the operating table wakes up.
And notice how Fury is holding what looks
like some kind of cold pack on his left eye.
Now, obviously, elsewhere in the trailer we
see a younger Fury before the injury that
led him to wear an eyepatch in the other MCU
movies.
So, I think that what we're seeing in this
scene is the aftermath of a fight with a Skrull
which caused Fury's left eye injury and led
him to have to wear an eye patch.
Also facing away from us is someone else who
looks to me like it could be Ben Mendelsohn.
You might know him as Krennic from Rogue One,
but in Captain Marvel he's playing the alien
Skrull, Talos, who arrives on earth and shape-shifts
into human form to hide among us in plain
sight.
Talos is the leader of the Skrulls who have
been at war with the alien Kree race and he
arrives on Earth to pose as a SHIELD agent
and secretly lay the groundwork for a Skrull
invasion.
And this scene gives us a glimpse of how perfectly
he seems to be blending in!
And as that shot of Talos and Nick Fury appears,
the trailer drops the following voiceover
line from Samuel L. Jackson: "space invasion".
Now that's another subtle indication that
Captain Marvel is drawing from the "Secret
Invasion" comic-book crossover storyline.
In that story, it's revealed that the shape-shifting
Skrulls have actually taken the place of many
of Marvel's superheroes, so it'll be interesting
to see if the Captain Marvel movie gives any
hints as to whether any of our favourite MCU
characters are actually secret Skrull imposters!
And that shocking shot of Captain Marvel thumping
what seems to be a poor old lady on the train
might have confused you if you weren't familiar
with the Skrulls.
But I suspect Carol's seen whoever she was
chasing on top of the train shape-shift into
a human form, or it could be that something
in the way the old lady smiles at Carol triggers
a memory or a reaction from her Kree background,
making her think this woman's a Skrull.
I wonder whether the real twist will be that
she's really is just an old lady and the attack
might put Carol on the authorities' radar
which could be how she eventually ends up
at SHIELD and meeting Nick Fury.
"So you're not from around here?"
"It's hard to explain"
The trailer also teases some cool new details
about Captain Marvel's origins which as Carol
Danvers says are definitely complicated.
Marvel's confirmed this won't be your typical
superhero origin story as the movie will begin
with Carol Danvers already having her powers
and she'll be part of a Kree elite unit called
Starforce.
The trailer teases a few shots of her fellow
Kree teammates.
On the right of Carol Danvers in the Starforce
shot is Minn-Erva, played by Gemma Chan.
Minn-Erva is an elite sniper and was the star
of the team before Carol joined, so you can
expect some rivalry between them in the movie.
There's Korath there, who you'll have seen
in Guardians of the Galaxy as the Kree mercenary
who'd been sent by Thanos to retrieve the
Orb which contained the Power Stone.
Because we're going back in time this will
be a younger Korath, though he's still played
by the same actor.
I suspect that the Captain Marvel movie will
show us why he and Ronan ended up allying
themselves with Thanos by the time of the
Guardians of the Galaxy movie.
By the way, Ronan appears very briefly in
the trailer with his back to us in this shot
here.
In charge of the team is Jude Law whose character
I think could be responsible for wiping Carol's
memories.
"I keep having these memories."
"I see flashes."
"I think I had a life here."
"But I can't tell if it's real."
The assumption so far with Law's character
is that he's playing Mar-vell, however, nobody's
been able to confirm who his character actually
is, meaning it could be part of a twist.
Let me know what you think.
OK, so this is a scene of an experiment or
procedure that I suspect Jude Law's character
may be performing on Carol.
Interviews with Brie Larson and Kevin Feige
have confirmed Captain Marvel is part-human,
part-Kree in the movie, as in the comics,
and let's just say this scene feels like she's
being turned into a Kree Winter Soldier.
This could be a twist on how she receives
her powers in the comics where she was caught
in a special piece of Kree technology that
altered her DNA making her a human-Kree hybrid
with superhuman powers.
Based on the trailer, there is another possibility
for how Carol gets her powers and that's when
she approaches some wreckage and seems to
be enveloped in a wave of blue light.
This might also match with another shot in
the trailer where she falls back and then
you see blue light around her hand.
An earlier version of the beeper that we saw
in the Avengers: Infinity War post-credits
scene makes an appearance in the trailer.
Although it's different, the buttons which
are visible do seem to the match the device
used in Infinity War.
The later version appears to be an enhanced
or augmented model with additional attachments
to the top and bottom.
The Infinity War model has also aged significantly
and the extra pieces may be necessary to be
able to communicate with Captain Marvel wherever
she's located at the time of Thanos acquiring
the Infinity Gauntlet.
There's also some really interesting foreshadowing
for Avengers 4 in this bit of voiceover from
Nick Fury:
"We have no idea what threats are out there."
"We can't do this alone.
We need you."
I think we'll hear that line towards the end
of this film, perhaps as Captain Marvel's
having to leave Earth for some reason.
Nick Fury will probably be letting Carol know
that he may need to use the beeper to contact
her again in the case of an emergency, which
is, of course, exactly what happens at the
end of Infinity War.
There's also an intriguing line at the end
of the trailer:
"I'm not who you think I am."
Notice there's a head just at the bottom of
the frame.
I think that could be Monica Rambeau the daughter
of Maria Rambeau who's Carol's air force colleague
and friend who we see earlier in the trailer.
Maria Rambeau, Monica's mother, goes by the
call sign "Photon" and in the comics, her
daughter Monica is actually the first female
Captain Marvel.
This is an interesting easter eggy twist of
sorts and probably a wink by Marvel to comic
book fans, but what I think is happening in
this scene is that either Carol is revealing
her superhero alter-ego to her fellow pilot
Maria or perhaps Maria has died and Carol's
telling her friend's daughter that she's not
the right person to look after her.
And if that is the young Monica in the bottom
of the shot, then it might be a tease for
a future super-powered Monica Rambeau in the
MCU.
Another comic book nod comes with several
shots of Carol Danvers with a helmet.
And if you look here, you can see the helmet
is being used to create her classic Mohawk
haircut from the comics.
And let's just appreciate this amazing final
shot of Captain Marvel fully powering up,
glowing bright and her eyes turning into pure
light.
Captain Marvel's powers include the ability
to absorb huge amounts of cosmic energy and
when she takes on enough she's goes "binary".
And there's also a cool easter egg on the
Captain Marvel poster as well.
If you look very carefully, you'll spot the
tail end of a cat here.
That's a nod to the comics where Carol has
a pet cat called Chewie, named after Chewbacca
from Star Wars.
The thing is that Chewie isn't actually a
cat, it's a member of an alien species called
the Flerken!
And there was another allusion to the feline-like
alien on some Captain Marvel cupcakes given
out at an event held at Marvel Studios!
Notice that cupcake with what look like a
cat's ID tag decoration on it, well that's
had the internet wondering whether comic-book
Chewie will be renamed in the MCU as Goose!
That would seem a bit weird given that Disney
own Star Wars, but then again, it would certainly
fit well with the Top Gun allusions in the
trailers!
Also on the poster are the words Higher, Further,
Faster, which is a tagline from Captain Marvel's
comics, specifically a run by writer Kelly
Sue DeConnick whose work has been a particular
influence on this film.
So, did the trailer get you hyped for the
Captain Marvel movie?
And what other details or easter eggs did
you spot?
Let me know your thoughts and theories and
make sure you leave a comment and subscribe
for a chance to win a cool Funko Pop.
Tap left to check out another Captain Marvel
video or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this a thumbs-up and a
share are always really appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!